-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning actor,
director, and producer you know
from his work in iconic films
such as "One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest," "Twins," and
"Matilda," and shows like "It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia."
He stars in the animated series,
"Little Demon,"
which airs Thursday nights
on FXX.
It is available to stream on
Hulu the next day.
Let's take a look.
-This is the metaphysical realm.
-Hmm, fancy.
-Hipsters call it the fringe,
which makes me want to punch
a hole in my face.
It's like the central hub
for all unearthly realms.
Think port authority but with
much, much, much more urine
and fewer bomb threats.
-So, if I call the shots,
does that mean
I don't have to listen
to anyone?
-Look at that guy.
He's got a bird head
and he craps bubbles.
I thought that was pretty cool.
-Please welcome back to the show
the legendary Danny DeVito,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
So happy you're here!
-Great to be here, buddy boy.
-How have you been?
-Really well. Really well.
Thank you.
-This is very exciting.
You're playing the devil.
-Yes, very close to home, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know if people can
quite tell from the clip
'cause, you know, you would hear
your voice, but that does not --
you do not look in the clip
like the devil.
-Let me do the devil thing.
-Yeah.
-I'm doing the devil thing
in real life.
-Yeah.
-Easy. [ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, so I -- we --
"Little Demon" is a comedy.
It's not for kiddies.
It's on FXX at 10:00
on Thursday nights.
And then it goes to Hulu,
like you said.
And, you know, it's just been
a blast because I'm working with
my daughter Lucy,
and my son, Jake.
And it's just off the charts
wonderful.
-So, Lucy is actually
the voice of --
-Of Chrissy, who is
the little demon.
She's the offspring
of the devil.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah.
She's the devil's spawn,
as you would.
And Aubrey Plaza
plays her mommy.
-Right.
-Aubrey is just -- Yeah.
-A very believable mother
of a demon.
-She's tough. She's a tough --
[ Laughter ]
She's a tough cookie,
let's put it that way.
-She is, a tough
and talented cookie.
One of our favorites.
-A very talented cookie.
And so, you know, the idea is
that she's been --
She had the baby, and she knows
it's the devil's -- mine.
And she's been hiding it from me
for 13 years.
And then what happens?
You know, usually when you're
13-ish and you're a woman,
you know what happens?
-Mm-hmm?
-[ Chuckles ]
-I mean, I think
if you don't know, it's --
you're the person to tell.
-That's right.
[ Laughter ]
So anyway.
At that stage in her life
when she has her period --
-Yep.
-I'll say it.
-Yeah, great.
[ Laughter ]
-She also starts realizing
these powers that she has.
And then she finds out
that her dad is not --
her mom told her that her dad
was not alive.
So, she finds out her dad
is the devil.
And that's me. And I come back
to insinuate myself in her life.
-[ Laughs ]
That is a wonderful premise.
-Yeah.
-And Lucy brought it to you?
-Yes, absolutely.
She called me one day, she said,
"Dad, we're thinking about doing
'Little Demon.'
There's a part
you were born to play."
I said, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
She said, "Satan."
Well, yeah.
It's a multifaceted part.
There's a lot to deal with when
you're the prince of darkness.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Oh, yeah.
-Nobody ever talks about just
the logistics of the day-to-day.
-You got to deal with people
who want your job.
-Right.
-Tony Soprano thought
he had it bad.
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah. But
the devil, on the other hand.
But this is not the first time,
even in recent history,
that you and Lucy
have worked together.
You guys were just doing a play
up in Vermont together?
-That's right.
We went to Vermont to --
Theresa Rebeck wrote us a play.
We have a three-hander,
like, three-character play.
And we workshopped it
at Dorset, Vermont.
It was great.
We had a great time.
Four days up there.
-Had you ever been on stage
with her before?
-We've done things -- No.
Well -- No, we've never done,
like, a theater piece together.
She's done a lot of theater.
I've done a lot of theater.
We've always wanted to work
together.
And now, we also are going to go
on stage to do a play,
which is like --
-So, I have to ask as a father.
Because, obviously as an actor,
you're on stage,
and you have to forget who you
are and become the character.
But as a dad, I can't imagine
being on stage
and not being proud of your --
-Oh. Oh, God. Off the charts.
-Does it get in the way
of being an actor?
-No, no, no. You've got to --
like, off the charts proud.
I mean, just, like, the fact
that she's in there doing it.
She and Jake are producing it.
It's like, you know, it's --
it's big-time stuff.
And animation is, like,
so complex and everything.
And I'm very, very proud of her.
In the show, I'm desperate to
be -- to spend time with her.
See? That's the whole idea,
the deadbeat dad --
I'm not a deadbeat dad,
I'm just saying.
You know, I'm like --
I'm the guy
who she's been hiding
the kid from.
So I'm desperate to spend time
with her.
I'm working my way out.
So, it's like a -- There's
a little family drama in there.
You know, when you're separated
parents and you're trying to vie
for the attention of
your precious daughter.
In my case, you know,
I get her every other weekend.
Which is not bad.
-Yeah.
-But I'd like her every week.
-I'd like to show her things.
-Yeah.
-I want to show her the --
Even the devil
wants to be a good dad.
-I want to be a good dad.
-Yeah, that's good.
-And I want to teach her things.
And I want to be a good role
model for my kid.
-Obviously in real life,
you have been a good role model.
All three of your kids
are in show business.
-Yes.
-Are you surprised by that?
-Well, no, I'm not surprised
because they, you know, were,
like, born in a trunk
kind of thing.
They were always on the stage.
They were on the set all
the time with me and Rhea, and,
you know, always exposed to it
and the whole Hollywood thing.
And they've turned out
really well.
My middle kid, Gracie,
who is my middle daughter,
she's a painter.
-Oh, was she? She's an artist.
-Yes, she's in the arts.
But Lucy's an actress
and Jake is doing the producing.
-What was the -- When they were
growing up, was there a piece of
yours that they were first drawn
to, seeing you on screen
that they liked?
-I think one of the scariest
things for me when is I did --
for me, was -- and for them,
I'm sure,
was when they watched me
get into makeup for the Penguin.
-Yeah, 'cause that was really --
-That was brutal.
-That was pretty grotesque
makeup. Yeah.
-That was really harsh.
You know, and I have a picture
of the three of them, like,
staring around, looking at me
getting the --
you know, the things put on.
But, you know, they were always,
like, really cool about it,
you know, being around
all the showbiz types.
-Well, that's great.
And I do think it's a tribute
to you and Rhea that they wanted
to choose that life.
-They wanted to do it, yeah.
-I got a lot more to ask you.
We're going to be
right back with more
from Danny DeVito
right after this.